[Music]
hey everybody all right yeah that was
right
not the nope we're not gonna do that
again we're good well there's a
different energy at our la shows Dave
yeah you ever noticed that when we go on
the road and people go apeshit yeah and
then in LA they just showed a different
name and then clam up right away you
ever notice that yeah you guys are a
bummer yeah yeah yeah I mean now that
you bottom-line did it feels like a bad
start a bad way to open I want to
congratulate all the old people they got
their candidate and now they're gonna
die in a pandemic what a legacy though
what a legacy to leave us that guy vote
yeah off you go to [ __ ] dead land but
still it's nice that we get to like our
nominee is now gonna be the guy in
Scrooged who talks to Bill Murray Yeah
right before he realizes that he's about
to go be visited by three ghosts I mean
we're present-day Marley we're two
months away from him him like bumping
into a guy in a factory floor and biting
the guy's tongue out vote for someone
else Jack as he's just eating the tongue
of a factory worker Joe Joe and there's
always the same woman behind it was like
alright alright leave Malone he's like
Jesus Christ he's talking to someone
again Joe to talk to but for someone
else Joe that's a window but for someone
else I see right through your [ __ ]
corn pop and I see right through you the
years 1941 I'm the quarterback of the
Houston whoopsies it's amazing how many
people are about to find out that he's
brain dead
it's gonna be what did I vote for oh
yeah a thriller extra fun to laugh
they're just good to have a life which
country do you want to move to huh no
America baby I want to move further into
it find a way to get deeper and deeper
into this bad boy yeah getting the fryer
of this [ __ ] you know I'm saying
day yeah yeah dig deep yeah well my
friend was gonna come tonight but he got
coronavirus anyway so you're welcome
yeah I call him up I was like I got you
on the list
oh no he he's in bed he has coronavirus
anyway things are good got two boxes of
water you're listening to the dollop
[Applause]
this is a bilingual American history
podcast for each week I Dave Anthony
read a story from American history in
Czechoslovakian to my friend Gareth
Reynolds who has no idea what's going on
or what the topic is going to be about
it's interesting did I not tell you this
one's in Czechoslovakia no but I'm sure
I'll be able to figure it out okay I
thought there would be more
I can hear you're rappers this is like
bein on Spotify
what kind of candy you got M&Ms that's
[ __ ] good M&Ms are good what happened
over here rattle in tonight's crowd work
bye Dave good it's like a pervy old gran
torino I can hear ya candy I could smell
you can do - what kind of candy is it
rub it up against the window no I'm just
knitting under the blanket no no I'm a
lonely old so-and-so I mean I was the
Democratic nominee in 2020 they are so
gonna replace that old [ __ ] after the
convention seriously Joe Biden's going
to the convention then they're gonna
make okay thanks Joe whoa I think he
just Tommy's president he'll have no
[ __ ] idea to build a set and put them
in there and you build a set I mean it
is four walls in a dream where's my
cabinet that's your cabinet right there
with all the the plates in it oh well I
wanted to talk about war policy shut the
door shut the door let's Jim we have a
guest he's hilarious
he has a Netflix he has I mean he's a
Netflix special new one ladies and
gentlemen Bert Kreischer yeah
[Applause]
there we go there we go
it's gotta be in that place known as the
machine or macchina oh yeah new special
Netflix you'll get it you'll get it one
more time it's a new special on Netflix
airing st. Patty's Day screaming st.
Patty's Day called a big boy check it
out very proud of it okay yeah see it
seemed like you were gonna say more I
felt like I was gonna say more and then
I was like what
I was like what are you gonna just do
the special I was I wrote like [ __ ] a
year ago you're like 18 months ago I've
been doing and then now with the
coronavirus that got memed and I'm
[ __ ] pissed I released the Instagram
yeah joke was by the way I'm I know that
a huge room dumb down bite your tongue
and dumb down for a second my wife well
[ __ ] me if if I'm sick and I was like
that's I I [ __ ] her definitely she's
sick she was like I don't want to get
you sick I was like well practice safe
sex and she's like you're gonna wear a
condom I was like no doggy style so you
coffee into the wall you got a cold
woman not AIDS anyway just spin around
doc holliday now and then obviously with
the corona virus being so popular that
joke comes out right when the corona
virus hits and then it gets [ __ ]
memed now I'm like it's great medical
advice though bear down girl you seem
like a really romantic husband
dude I've already planned out my
Instagram strategy by your coronavirus
of course oh yeah
go to an air B&B up in the woods right
hey it's birthday two with the
coronavirus it's gonna be like I am
Legend just be in front of a computer in
a lab coat I've been running a lot of
tests on myself
turns out whisky is not helping how far
away is he he's in Big Bear he's about a
90-minute drive he's not far at all how
do you not have grown up iris yet just
stepping down your game son that's true
okay
February 17th 1873 hmm
William Edward Riker was born in Oakdale
California into a family of six can we
just call him Riker I was gonna call him
William but I guess Riker way cooler
Riker all right all right so when was
Riker born very little is known about
his family and childhood he dropped out
of school by the fourth grade Wow and
his father died when he was 17 what are
they walking confident fourth grader I'm
done I don't wanna learn cursive I'm out
there's so much more I got there just a
bit feel pretty good
this shit's pretty easy I'm ready for
college I'm a white man this world's
made for me let's do it I'm in charge
now oh my god sitting on an Apple box on
a car just driving a car been in a car
in this scenario for sure that's right
everybody it's me Riker I'm in the
fourth grade automobiles
[Laughter]
I'll fax you later
essentia fax Tommy all right bye-bye
Riker out what's the Wi-Fi uh so two
years after his dad died a Rikers mother
remarried and they moved to San
Francisco he worked different jobs his
main income came from selling
miscellaneous goods on the street sure
it's like he just sold [ __ ] on the
street
come on guys ever I got a bunch of
string I'm trying to move those are shoe
laces nah damn it look get out of here
you bad for business guy
[Laughter]
while that Riker became interested in
spiritualism and soon quote started
preaching his divine message on the
street corners and in assembly halls
everywhere anywhere that people would
listen here we go and we're off there it
is by the way much better when you said
spiritualism I thought you're gonna say
spearfishing
and I was like I'm gonna like this story
and it took a turn for the worse do a
lot more damage with religion don't
worry about the spearfishing story the
guy just goes to an island and spear
fishes the end wait we should do one
where we do a choose-your-own-adventure
that spear fish I'd like him to be a
spear fisherman if that's all right with
everybody so Riker was very good-looking
and intensely magnetic which attracted
crowds especially young women okay he
preached his message up and down the
west coast of California but traveling
was expensive and preaching didn't cover
the cost here we go
so Williams started charging for palm
readings there it is and then he stuck
and then he moved on to mind-reading and
called himself Professor Riker by the
way a lot of palm readers are doing that
in the corona day and age now they're
moving from palm to mind
just like you just like why'd you cross
that palm I do mine now sit down
professor Riker caught on and he went on
a national mind-reading tour that's
great
he became a very well-known carnival
attraction I know what you guys are
thinking up here who picked that shirt
[Laughter]
so what do you do for a living just
kidding already no doctor right no get
him out of here so when he was in
Colorado Springs he met and married a
woman named marine yet a few years later
he met a woman named Bessie zeti and
they married sorry for those of us
keeping track of the wives yeah I think
there's two yes yeah and there was not
an in-between well I know men so why
don't you fall in love married yep once
well then you wait for that process then
say you and then say you meet another
person you're like she's great then you
marry that one no that's not no I like
this guy's style all right there it is
but of course I'm a misogynist so they
had a son named Francois Villon ooh
right which said Bessie the sexy second
was okay but then Bessie found out that
Ryker was also had been married before
and was still married yeah so she went
to the district attorney and filed
bigamy charges okay and then Ryker fled
to Canada
interesting by himself for with the
first one just took off by himself nice
Canadian single yeah totally
I'm Canadian single a so he's in Canada
starts touring again as Professor Riker
the mind reader when a mind reader did
not see the bigamy charges coming away
skit add a little sooner and in his
spare time he worked diligently to
invent a new ideology philosophy and
religion which he then called quote the
perfect Christian divine way Burt's
intrigued it's like I'm trying to think
I'm trying to think okay
you'd be besties and I'm gonna be Riker
okay know that I'm a mind reader tell me
what a divorce all right
Riker I know what you're gonna say do I
even need to tell you where I'm going
listen she means nothing just right for
that joke every time
look she means nothing to me she's
packing her bags you forgot your shoes
[Laughter]
you there so what do you do for a living
you are never gonna believe this start
his Island let's do this so his new
religion and philosophy showed people
how to get closer to God by practicing
the following tenants a separation of
the sexes okay
abandoning alcohol just yesterday you
think you've lost a lot of people
honestly being born again total
segregation of the races Jesus Christ
and believing in white supremacy well
that list got a little crazier as you
went on figured out a way to give that
an echelon so the classic like Jesus
yeah yeah just do I mean yeah honestly
roots and ladies separate gotta really
believe in Jesus also white people are
better than everybody yeah it's like
it's a Texas bachelor party as one of
the tenants of the religion all you
needed to say wasn't you got to get
hammered on a boat so he was there for
five years and he returned to the US I
was in Omaha touring and he met and
married a woman named Lucille Jensen now
what no okay we don't know we have some
no I heard we have no idea if he's
married or divorced at this point I
think he's still married because he just
ran off to Canada well we assume he's
divorced why cuz I think the women would
divorce him and say abandonment he
doesn't see he dropped out of fourth
grade he doesn't seem like a guy who
finishes a lot of things yeah I think I
I agree I think he treated it like
fourth grade boys like I think I'm done
with this yeah you don't need to know
anything more and then he just leaves
lawns you're under arrest for bigamy no
I'm over it I'm gonna get in that car I
made so he went on tour spreading his
message of the perfect Christian divine
way and when the tour was over he had
eleven disciples well he really limited
is demographic I mean it was like you've
got to be a white non drinking man in
this time yeah yeah I mean well you
could be a woman you just have to be
separate yeah hang out together then
your parts might rub together and
you guys know that goes I mean Burt does
it to a little machine in this kitchen
but the rest of us go to the spray wall
[Laughter]
so they all followed him to San
Francisco Ajo it's a great place for
guys who don't party and just want to be
by themselves with whites William put
his disciples up in a house on Hay
Street which became the headquarters for
the divine way the Kamiya grew and local
cobblers printers and general store
owners were quote thriving and
supporting Rikers quest for for becoming
the great Emancipator so what that's his
goal to be the great Emancipator that's
what he said yeah we kind of break ah
cut us loose from all this [ __ ] and
alcohol give it to the blacks rank are
you sure know what you're doing friend
everything spearfishing not a bit a
better path so we record demanded his
disciples call him father
and his wife he made them call her
mother so and his wife is allowed to be
around yeah yeah he oh he's not separate
from no sexes someone's got a [ __ ] yeah
yeah that's a great commandment
now now now to fund this whole deal he
made them quote free themselves of
worldly concerns
yeah I mean they just have to talk about
it time for them to be like so come we
have alcohol or no that's how I free
myself from my worldly concerns I by the
way this sounds like any black guys wet
dream is give us all the booze on all
the [ __ ] and the white guys are gonna
get the [ __ ] out of here like okay
looking at us from that window up there
like orphans looking at gruel orphans
looking at gruel look at gruel you're
gonna get to in the next few years so
basically he's that he was saying free
themselves worldly concerns by donating
all of their wealth and property to him
to him okay right so the deal for him I
completely understand yes sounds like a
pretty good deal for him especially rich
members like Frieda Schwartz who sold
her property and gave all the profits to
Ryker okay in September of 1918 he filed
the Articles of Incorporation for the
perfect Christian divine way shut
incorporate was the name taken or no no
what was it again the perfect decrypt
the perfect Christian divine way he's
now he's not officially a business right
that year woman who lived on Hayes
Street father complained that the
communes non-stop buzzsaw was too loud
well I couldn't find anything else about
that leave it that's part of our deal
lead the bus on well no drinking no
[ __ ] buildings can bound to happen at
some point
so I had to go to a hearing and at the
hearing the judge asked William quote
isn't it your principle to do unto
others as you would have them do unto
you know right Riker said quote no our
faith is founded on this principle mind
your own business boom I find you guilty
[ __ ] how's that rancors back
baby whoo give me on your shoulders come
on keep the buzz get your [ __ ] out of
here
what the [ __ ] you lookin at what kind of
candy is that and no booze no [ __ ] no
blacks by 1919 the divine Way had a lot
of money and they bought 75 acres in the
Santa Cruz Mountains Jesus ten miles
south of Los Gatos the land was
undeveloped and surrounded by for sin
William had access to building material
that had been left over from the 1906
earthquake so they took it to the
mountains and Bank began constructing
their own town Ryker called it holy city
seems like the first try yeah well you
couldn't have you couldn't question him
he's the authority
what do you guys think the holy city
it's pretty good to speak up which would
be backhanding God in the [ __ ] face
good it's great yeah it's great isn't it
yeah holy city really rolls off the
tongue there Ryker ah that's right it
does this side isn't perfect we're gonna
get jackets made too and it's all we can
wear and if you take it off it's a sin
yeah are you gonna wear one I don't need
to wear one I get to bend the rules I'm
right baby baby whoo rockers back so the
divine ways membership was now up to 30
yeah right 30 people holy [ __ ] I know
holy city this guy has the same growth
as my career and then I'm an open record
[Laughter]
[Music]
seventy-five acres in the city for 30
people I said you don't know Holies city
jack a lot of people said we can do this
in one house but I said 75 acres most of
the 30 were elderly put your jacket on
come on holy Teddy no no all right don't
be no more questions they'll be only
sitting murders pardon he's facing the
tree this Mothe demands freedom that is
it legal bird
but even though their LD elderly records
still put him to work
he had them build small poorly built
shacks deliver and live in and they had
to live separate from their spouses
that's two houses I gotta build yes
that's right I promise I won't touch her
I just don't know if physically I can
build and whether [ __ ] sit around
yappin and get a hammer old man oh okay
goodbye my love no bingos when you're
done building nineteen houses well I'm
not close to bingo wait hold on I have a
question what what was considered
elderly in the 1800's thirty-five anyway
I'm definitely elderly in these 43 year
old senior citizens I think it's the
same I think it's like sixties William
Lee sorry wrecker lives in a two-story
home that overlooked the land his walls
were covered with pictures of his wife
Marilyn Monroe George Washington Abraham
Lincoln and Adolf Hitler what backup
what year is this this is every year and
the how old's Ryker he's out of high
school right yes it's 1900 well now
we're the 19th others so it's 1930 20
Marilyn Monroe what your shoes fifties
oh god that is weird why Monroe Jobs I
see every seven years there'll be an
itch over a storm drain shall protect
herself maybe that was later on I got
put there but that doesn't make sense
it's gotta be wrong well Hitler too
though Hitler's in the 30s yeah it might
have been pictures that he put up over
time okay so he's sort of like a rolling
stone gathering
weird mom yeah yeah because the house is
gonna be around for a while
so William advertised Holy City as a
religious place yeah I don't think he
needed to do that
it's religiously based but it was more
focused on making money he had his
disciples build businesses that would
attract tourists like soda stands art
shops gas station and restaurants you
mean all that stuff they have in the
cities they live in now they have them
here closer to a city but the gas
station
bill jess76 no problem sure sure thing
sounds a lot like cocoon the petrol
station Riker none of us know what to do
how does that work at all you don't have
said well the car was just becoming
popular and the road was built thanks to
this guy yeah a road was built from San
Jose to Santa Cruz and Holy City put a
gas station in garage and a bank there
Wow william distribute distributed
pamphlets advertising holy city from one
quote the founders of holy city are the
wisest of all wise men a ten thousand
dollar chief did someone grow up in holy
city like you went to a holy city high
back build be a high school Wow that was
what was the name of their team mascot
holy city a ten thousand dollar
challenge to the whole world who wishes
to debate upon the subject of politics
or religion and win the debate be sure
and stop at the holy city for good eats
at city prices sorry the lure is first a
debate on government where you can win
$10,000 but also get a soda it's at city
prices
god forbid you get a deal because you're
driving 75 miles out of the city they're
getting you City prices that's right a
city discount 75 miles out we come dick
do everything you could do down the
street and holy city and we jack up the
prices like there's competition next
door holy city drive over the dead
people who are constructing everything
holy city william taught that quote the
white man and the jewish race were
supreme while the Negro and Orientals
are inferior races Jesus Christ
welcome to Holy City where we don't have
a basketball team so he believes he has
eventually as a picture of Hitler on his
wall but believes that that his people
and the Jews are the are the chosen
people right it's a little contradictory
well yeah the Jewish thing doesn't go
along with Hitler much that's what I'm
finding the road that's what I'm
noticing a rub yeah there's a there's a
little contradiction there well but you
can have heroes or not and do it in
everything they do
let's know that's a big component of him
that's big it's the big one
that's the headlines and Hitler talk
about that oh yeah okay we should keep
going I thought we put a pin in this and
come back to it I like that idea
celibacy was mandatory and disciples
could not mingle with the opposite sex
but different rules for Ryker he was he
that he then married a second woman
named Lillian Frieda Schwartz a second
woman there's no Asians there second
woman the math works out a freed anyone
getting that [ __ ] joke as his fourth
[ __ ] wife Frieda
Jesus Christ no not in holy city Frieda
Schwartz who was a mother of eight was
very pissed off when he married a second
woman she was also one of holy city's
biggest donors and she made allegations
that kicked off a federal investigation
oh the cult was indicted for obtaining
money under false pretenses and
conspiring to corrupt public morals
freitas husband sued for ten thousand
and then local media went into a frenzy
contradictory stories appeared once that
Freda claimed her husband was given two
wives and that their eight children were
taken from them to be raised in the cult
but Riker was able to do this by saying
it was how the Schwartz family would get
into heaven
wait Freda is married is still married
freeze married to a guy and then she
just bounced from the marriage takes
what eight kids goes to Riker no they're
both they both go into the cult okay
okay he separates them and be raised by
the core which is the best way to raise
for sure yeah let the animals raise them
in this village
yeah he takes a village thank you by the
way I found the loophole in the Jewish
thing
but his biggest donor was free to
Schwartz hey you check clear just giving
you a heads up and the Jews are okay
Hitler's got some other ideas about
gypsies but you know I don't believe
I've ever heard Hitler say anything like
that but I'll look it up again just to
make sure so he gave Frida's husband I'm
gonna make sure we're spell this the
same way there's a lot of heads Hitler's
a very popular name in Germany isn't
Smith over there
[Laughter]
so that she comes there and then he puts
us husband-wife he gives though he gives
the husband a new lady so she he's got
you know two wives
it's all so record was able to do this
by saying it was how the Schwarz man
that would get it to have him free to
quote I was not allowed to even mention
my children's name again if I did they
abuse me
she also said Riker made all the women
in Holy City have sex with them and if
they got pregnant they had to have
abortions I mean that is such like that
that's just classic cult leader but I
mean that really is just like the
prototype this sounds this is gonna
sound very from left field right no I
don't think I think everyone's prepared
I feel like there's a lot we could learn
from a guy like Riker yes
I wish I had the confidence of a cult
leader you just like Shoeless Joe
Jackson
[Laughter]
Tiwa so Alexander Schwartz said his
children were constantly beaten and tied
to trees in order to be stretched Jesus
Christ to be stretched figure out what
the [ __ ] that meant but I think trying
to make them bigger yeah like an Iron
Maiden sort of stretching apparatus I
saw it in the Brady Bunch
yeah yeah it was concerned with his
height and so he stretched everyday and
it didn't help I was hoping it was gonna
be a punishment that they passed down No
so local authorities quickly removed for
the children including Rikers son from
Holy City but the oldest Schwartz kid
said his parents were lying without any
of the Schwartz children they wouldn't
that kids wouldn't say anything they
said it was they said it wasn't true
right so without that physical evidence
the judge dismissed the case against
William in 1923 so no one knows if the
Schwartz claims were legitimate but the
1920 census shows he was secretly paying
rent
for house in San Francisco where he kept
seven women including free to separate
from their husbands oh my god I got up
seven or seven days in a week
oh wait he was keeping them like at his
side now I think they were there were
cult members so they were they were I
don't know if they were kept they were
just like living with him and he was
[ __ ] [ __ ] them all yeah no pictures
just for reference not like I'm sorry
I mean Frida Schwartz doesn't sound sexy
sorry it's the 1800s and she's an old
lady's eight [ __ ] kids and her
husband gave this guy Riker am i reading
this story wrong well it's not the 1800s
Yeah right right 420 grams like listen I
need some [ __ ] distance from the old
lady that's what it sounds like my
hearing is wrong I'm not the best
listener
no it's kind of sounds right okay got
air quoted I'm a horrible listener
because I my imagination goes off when I
start listening that's why I couldn't
remember what the geisha keep going okay
weird yeah it's an open door by the way
you would I don't think it'd be shocked
to hear this but I am NOT a good outloud
reader Bert the door just cracked open a
little further you do an eight-part er I
wrote a book and I had to read the
audiobook and it took me 25 hours to
read it there's a five hour audio I
can't read out loud at all
uh-huh you got to start recording audio
books or a foundation for people who
can't read out loud okay yeah oh yeah
let's shift to that gear you know birth
that's amazing and I think you should
start a charity and here's why do you
have a hard time reading out rap [ __ ]
god damn it we'll go from the top here
at crushers kids go ahead burger
read what the man has on the card so
even with the case drop the Schwartz
family hoped that negative press would
hurt holy city's tourism and leave it
bankrupt but the opposite happened
because of the trial people were now
curious and tourists flocked to holy
city of course Riker was part of the
draw he was always in a white suit and
sometimes had his little dog beside him
he walked around the town shouting at
tourists quote I offered ten thousand
anybody who can find the flaw in my 100%
arguments where did you read that right
yes 100% arguments yeah in a white suit
with a dog next to it yeah tourists
would not take him up on it and then
would start avoiding him yeah put them
off no wait what is what like if you had
to give everyone pick your 100% argument
that you would your Hill to die on your
100% argument I'll start quantum leap is
the best time travel movie TV show ever
I was die on that hill that's a really
good one it's a [ __ ] great it's a
great one I love your zoo I could
quantum leap into a moment I quantum
leap into you so I could take yours Wow
talk about the leap home whoo I wouldn't
do it one time and honorable sorrows
office was there I saw it I said he'd
created quantum leap I go he's mister
Belisario in he goes he is and his doors
open his office I go I talk to him she
goes do a meeting and he stuck his head
up and go mister Belisario I love
quantum leap thank you so much and I
just walked out I follow his daughter on
Instagram that's easy god really creepy
she's 9 and she is ok I do not know how
old she is
stop right there Bert
now's when you look into the camera go
oh boy oh boy so so many tourists were
coming to holy city that was now
bringing in a hundred thousand dollars a
year with any money they bit more
restaurants a comfort station and an
observatory
Recker had a new billboard went up at
the entrance quote Holy City answers all
questions and solves all problems see if
you are contemplating marriage suicide
or crime the big three Wow
one billboard yeah holy city kept
building and they now had a fully
equipped garage super-super service
station soda stands an auditorium a
dance ballroom a lecture hall a motion
picture studio a notary public a holy
city silver grocery store it sounds like
butcher shop and more it was a fully
operational town it sounds like a child
putting together a city gotta have
another Republic and a motion picture
studio yeah
they built a radio station kfq you it
had programs like a daily 30-minute
Swiss yodeler huh I mean that would
still work if you're I'm telling you
right now if you're still working in
that business called radio if you put on
a show where it was 30 minutes of one
yodeler not repeating his yodel once
even if he repeats it we're not gonna
know
[Music]
yeah you're listening to KF QW that
would [ __ ] work do you realize how
many eyes there be just be in traffic
yodel ha ha ha I might Google that
tonight see if I can find 30 minutes of
straight yodel I'm sure you can sure
some shitty comics down as a podcast
yodelers aren't known for their editing
you'll be fine
I want to hear yodel or have an orgasm
[Music]
[ __ ] your lair lair the guy had some
good ideas is what we mean to say
[Laughter]
there's also town bands announcements
and then in-between Riker rambled about
his philosophy this is my impression of
the yodeler in the office seeing Riker
walk down realizing Rikers next you lay
off [ __ ] and the blacks the Federated
Commission eventually shut down for not
operating in the public interest but
even though he was cracking down on a
religious nation yeah I've been pretty
abysmal not even shot them down yeah but
yeah but the euros I could even hear me
if we found out you were just saying
[ __ ] over and over again Joseph and
we're not happy about it uh even though
he was building businesses and and he'd
still had not built a church sure but
right after the mall yeah yeah record
kept claiming holy city was a religious
sanctuary but locals didn't see it that
way
when describe it as nothing more than a
quote white supremacist hangout attached
to a roadside attraction and sure enough
Rikers soon put up another billboard
quote our California belongs only to the
white race it must be purged of this
deadly polluting oriental disease oh my
god stop there a billboard a billboard
yeah what are you thinking for the sick
one Riker I think we go bigger boom SEPA
that gets the people talking in 1928
Evelyn Rosencrantz claimed Riker had
lived with her for two months in Palm
City and he promised to marry her she
wanted to sue for breach of promise he
had been immediately attracted to her
when he met her holy city a member quote
she told him she had been forced to
serve a term in prison for forgery to
save her 21 year old son and Riker
believed her but she'd actually been put
in San Quentin three times for caching
bad checks so we're just we've abandoned
the premise that he is a mind reader in
any capacity right he's now just a
[ __ ] right here's a liar okay Riker
didn't care about her past he gave her a
copy of his diamond key book which
included the ten commandments for women
living in the Divine way a little bit
revised now when she threatened to sue
record did everything he could to get
the book back but the media got ahold of
it oh no his shady Ten Commandments Evan
Evelyn next claimed Riker had promised
to make her a star of a movie called the
perfect woman and after was going to fly
her to Rome in a custom plane named
spirit of love she's really fallen for
just [ __ ] well I mean he built a
mall and Holy See the movie studio yeah
although it was never used and it was
turned into a dorm well
I mean that happens all the time in
Hollywood I mean Burt met a Belisario
yeah it's a crazy world yeah I have a
production company we don't even our
office yeah see since the opposite
he's got the opposite issue you throw
Burton holy city holy [ __ ] you of a
marriage
Jesus yeah I'm going through a big Asian
kick right now like food-wise it's like
they know my tongue my god
please never say that again to another
he lawsuit ended suddenly what Evelyn
was sent to San Quentin jail for trying
to cash another bad check it was her
fourth offense so she was sentenced to
life without parole he keeps looking out
Wow bad checks Jesus Christ
now Ryker lost a lot of money fighting
the lawsuit so he demanded even more
from his disciples at this time oh I
don't know what they are at this time he
also got super into Cadillacs it's
that's the phase you want to go through
when you're financially unstable your
Cadillac phase you started buying and
collected him he quickly became known
for driving recklessly around town and
getting dozens of tickets in one year in
Santa Cruz okay I was gonna say sorry
the rules are rules come on Jimmy it's
me I have a friend a dragon I'm gonna
[ __ ] your wife well you're a bright girl
that brings me to the citation piece of
[ __ ] Rach are you and that little weird
dog ears aren't you you dick Oh that'll
be five spirit credits in 1928 in Santa
Cruz Ryker ran over two pedestrians
hey hey it happens by the way
mind you he did not have a cell phone in
his hand he was just staring at the road
and ran over my god he broke he broke
both their legs and they suffered
internal injuries he got a fine
and tickets said he paid it yeah there
you go
for bad checks jail for life running
people running people over with your
Cadillac billed on fake religious money
a slap on the wrist he was pulled over
in San Mateo for driving on the wrong
side of the road while doing 40 miles an
hour in a 24 in heaven that's the side
we drove on he was fine $10 when he paid
the ticket the police said quote the
king of holy city launched into a
fervent sermon on his religious
teachings yeah it's the joke was meant
for the thirties [ __ ] not today God
open your [ __ ] minds that's quite a
switcheroo you know so myself and I'll
hold on how do I get out stand on their
shoulders I can't believe you won people
over he's like a quantum leap er up
there a los gatos banker said Riker
would drive up to the local bank in a
Cadillac with his dog and the dog would
wait in the car quote while his master
was doing his banking wrecker
in all the cash and had yellow checks
made up with pick a picture of Jesus in
one corner he would sit and talk and
talk boring anyone within earshot with
his ramblings and divine thoughts when
his dog got tired of waiting in the car
he would put his pop on the horn and
blast away why it's that dog not leading
the cult that that's the guy holy [ __ ]
and then rekar would come out of the
bank
that's [ __ ] apparently Riker treated
this dog better than he treated anyone
else yes this dog had the balls be like
wrap it up [ __ ] by the way if you
work if you work in that bank from the
second he comes in you're just like that
horn dog come on out the back about free
lollipops in the bank I'll tell you
another thing this is a bit religious to
not to get all pious on you just put
this checked over they're dead just
getting warmed up with y'all well my
only brother Jesus been a real [ __ ]
[Music]
you bad boy you dog was it I don't know
whenever it was a man in a suit man in a
suit when the Great Depression hit holy
city served over 42,000 meals to
transients in exchange for an hour of
work despite the times holy city thrived
some visitors even likened it to a theme
park quote they were confronted with
races Vail they were confronted with
signs placards loud music and Riker
himself preaching for His perfect
philosophy to anyone who would listen
and even if they didn't listen
you could eat drink gas your car and
look at the penny peep shows which
offered temptations such as the crudely
made legs of Queen Elizabeth of Egypt
what wait hold on holy city is a [ __ ]
business but can you you can't get you
don't get free gas there no you don't
get free guys you get like free you get
free I mean if you sit there and listen
to this guy just ramble on you get free
food yeah you could eat right but then
in this town of shows where you would
look at the legs you'd sure okay just
wanted to make sure cuz a lot came at us
they're so famous Queen Elizabeth the
beach
upon my history well I don't think
that's not a stuff my brain with the
spices in tea and a couple of cubes of
sugar on the side in 1929 the IRS
declared holy city and no longer takig
attacked tax-exempt as a religion
because none of their profits were from
donations so Ryker came up with a plan
to get the tactics and exemptions back
he hired a carnival promoter the
carnival promoter thought wrecker was
out of his mind and went and told the
San Francisco Examiner of his plan the
examiner had this guy's out of his
[ __ ] mind he's opening a theme park
and he's got little Nations in how the
[ __ ] are we gonna turn a dollar here
[Laughter]
like for a carnival barker to be like
this guy's out of his mind I guess
waiting Shepherd lions and this guy he's
oh so this and that's how he walked in
the san francisco he was just like hey
that's it so the examiner had to
reporters pretend to be con men and they
set up a meeting with Riker in a hotel
room while and in the joining room a
stenographer a judge and a physician
listened in a physician medically
speaking why am I here
no god damn it I said magician not a
foot [ __ ] the doctor I do do a
handkerchief gag in the room record told
the reporters he wanted to build a
17,000 person amphitheater and he would
market the amphitheater as a church take
donations from the audience and get his
tack exemption status back there is your
typing next door everyone got that right
literally listen every time I pause it
stops and then when I start again she's
doing it again you hear that right what
happiness I'm not saying it's a sheep
for sure I don't want to be that guy
Sammy Sosa's or others he's [ __ ] see
how fast I wished they must be on
vacation anyway she's not letting loose
what was I saying 17,000 burst
amphitheater that's the one so there he
would set up elaborate smoke and mirror
contraptions to perform magic secretly
hook audience members up to wires and
make them levitate he was going to have
si secretly hook him up to wires yeah
yeah so drugged who knew I'm barely a
vehicle for these he was going to have
divine way members fake disabilities and
then healed them he said quote my people
will do anything I tell them to do to
them I am God the undercover reporters
asked him why you want to do this and he
said quote there are three kinds of
people those would do the intelligent
ones and those without dough wait that
seems like there should be more yeah it
definitely feels like he had four on his
list than he had well he's saying he's
think so he's saying you either have
money or you're smart or you don't have
money yeah so shouldn't he say
intelligent with money there's like I
think Bert's right look there's three
types of people people who drive people
eat Chinese food and people would like
dogs that's it
oh dear
by the way I'm just stupid enough to
hear those less than three people and oh
not here then go I wonder which one I am
[Laughter]
[Music]
complement the reporters wanted to see
how he would take it so one lived in
holy city for a week acting as a
contractor planning construction for the
amphitheater I think they sent another
reporter sure so the reporters then
wrote articles and they came out and
Riker denied it and said he knew about
the reporters deception all along the
amphitheater was never built but Holy
City saw another massive spike in
tourism because of the Arctic William
decided to publish more pamphlets and
now charge for them from a pamphlet
titled can you imagine someone charging
I'd be like you go [ __ ] yourself forever
this one's about [ __ ] yourself
forever how much it's five bucks yeah
yeah I'll take five that's a ripoff the
final wisdom it was called the final
wisdom and understanding for you quote
mortal woman is man's only legitimate
enemy all right strong opener and mortar
mortal man is her only legitimate
undeveloped child in the end in the end
when developed both will be human beings
at peace and not arguing men and women
if it feels like he has liked the poem
magnets and someone just put those
together work yeah sounds like he's
doing that that clickbait before anyone
else yeah I read that I go mortal man is
gonna read this [ __ ] thing it's a
slide of 18 just keep clicking the arrow
every three will be an advertisement
that's why did I do this [ __ ] see how
much press wait precious loss did you
have you done that one every time I saw
that picture [ __ ] these things okay bye
19:30 holy city had over 300 members
living there Wow Wow
most were men weird boner City God none
of them got pay but they got room and
board and they had to do tasks to upkeep
holy city holy city continue to thrive
through the early 30s it avoided bad
publicity only Rikers car accidents were
an issue but he somehow was never
seriously injured and never killed
anyone
[Laughter]
terrible return holy city in 1935 Ryker
wrote to President Roosevelt look he
contact he claimed that he could quote
make kings and queens out of all sane
minded white people and the country
could be turned into a paradise on short
notice for some reason Roosevelt never
responded yeah
Roosevelt like turned to an aide it was
like invent the paper shredder
[Music]
Riker published a 22-page pamphlet
called the Emancipator and he all
disciples calling mr. shaking the
pamphlet label yeah he's really the
pamphlet was about running for governor
which he then did perfect he listed
himself on the ballot as quote caucasian
reactionary very conservative isolated
anti-semite catholic oh so he's turned
against the jews now no even though he
wasn't Catholic and still like Jewish
people he just thought it would be good
way to get folks oh yes it's just it's
smart marketing it's just a smart
marketing I just feel in the room man I
know what's going on branding uh it's
the vote for someone else campaign
that's right yeah he lost the election
in a landslide
what and then he found a new person to
write to Adolf Hitler oh my lord
here we go quite a turnaround when you
get rebuffed by Roosevelt I'm sure you
hear this all the time endeavor I have a
pen pal
come to bed no no no Rikers writing me
again ah good boys I don't think he
really doesn't like Jews personally the
way I don't what actually am i doing now
I just I'm still astounded you know who
Ava is I couldn't tell you her last name
right now I went is it Braun or Gardner
its broad stating Ava Gardner talk about
a quantum leap you know Hitler had a dog
yeah it backfired on him because he beat
the [ __ ] out of the dog oh just oh my
god now people oh no Hitler beats dogs
I like it one bit anymore
I hung it there as long as I could but
you put the fear of God in animals
you've made an enemy mr. boy 16 times
shame on me that monster now you've
checked my box
don't touch your face he's crying he's
got to don't touch your face man
oh no no touch it all over and say we
gave you the coronavirus it's so so
funny I just got it so he starts writing
data of Hitler William thought there was
a like-minded soul and referred to him
as his honor his excellency and a second
Martin Luther oh my god distinction must
be made I heard that man with weight and
then I was like you know he does
time-travel cuz he had all these
pictures up there yeah that's one I
don't see but okay whatever you say in
one letter Riker I wrote quote your
opportunity is now ripe when and when it
is done you will prove yourself to the
greatest character that has ever lived
since the time of Jesus Christ you will
not only succeed in whipping all enemies
but will cause yourself and millions of
others to experience happiness far
greater than words will explain and I'm
a mind reader that actually is kind of
the opposite of what happened yeah I
mean it was already sad but then it's
like really oh my god getting ghosted by
Hitler likes writing writing fan letters
to Adolf Hitler and then being like he
rebuffed me like oh so you interesting
a few years later during the war some
American soldiers visited holy city in
William ran out to greet them and then
he asked them to abandon their fight
against Hitler and allow him to take
over Europe so America could focus on
defeating quote the non-white Japanese
military also if you guys want a movie
we have a movie house if you're worried
what you're gonna do after you've
abandoned your mission to [ __ ] elderly
he handed them pamphlets which he wanted
them to distribute at a Moffett Field
which is the base and said quote Hitler
had adopted some of my ideas yeah yeah
he's not the kind of write back friend
but he's definitely the adopt your
policies cuz he read your [ __ ] for sure
got a friend we drive on the left side
here by the way I'm the only one who
drives he's like I had a joke about
doggystyle with my wife and then Hitler
put out a meme the next day a hundred
percent that he aggregated that for me
the soldiers did not take the pamphlets
and hand them out but instead went and
told the FBI who charged William Riker
with sedition
you mean he drugged them and at the
beginning of the trial Riker was not
happy with his lawyer and he fired him
he hired an up-and-coming young lawyer
named Marvin oh sorry Melvin belli bail
eyes defense tactic was to downplay
Rikers influence and intelligence he
repeatedly during the trial called Riker
a crackpot oh and that is so perfect cuz
for Riker a man purely fueled by ego to
have to sit there and constantly have
him disparage him and he's paying him
he's like me right now grinding his
teeth like a dumbass look at his stupid
stupid to you I wish he was smart enough
to pull off some of these things but
unfortunately my client is just far
tubes
stupid you dumb [ __ ] ah rest your honor
let me tell my client I'm a done asking
questions now whoo Bell a said quote his
efforts were pitiful and pathetic but
they were not seditious and it worked
he was not convicted wow this dude
witnesses said he left quote the
courtroom with a small American flag in
his pocket and climbed into his red
white and blue sedan
trip away where he hit nine reporters on
the way out but Ryker was not happy even
though he was acquitted he resented felt
like calling him a crackpot repeatedly
yep say like that son of a [ __ ] so in
ballet a striker to pay his $5,000 bill
record said quote my son I shall reward
you with a seat in my kingdom of heaven
and that is far more humble int then
appalled tree $5,000 spell I did sued
Ryker and easily won but when I'm in
heaven you can hang on the kingdom
crackpot to 40 virgins the whole nine
you're gonna love it
Peter sorry
he was now he's not now started really
hemorrhage members from Holy City a a
big part of this was because of his
behavior there were now 75 men and four
women
oh those women were like alright don't
break the circle back to back
hold your knives out we're gonna get the
[ __ ] out of here girls keep moving
nobody take your eyes off of most guys
are good there we go all right
rotate rotate rotate
[Music]
[Laughter]
don't see burnt watch a special telling
himself jokes do you realize how many
bad jokes I've dropped but how many I've
edited [ __ ] out Riker would love the
jokes going on in my head
in 1940 a construction of highway 17 was
finished
it went from Santa Cruz to Los Gatos and
a completely bypassed holy city entirely
no no holy cities tourism
profits plummeted then America began
rationing gas for the war that was holy
city's second source of income and holy
city was now not turning a profit but
instead blowing through money to try and
reignite interest in holy city Rikers
started touring and preaching again but
everyone was more concerned about world
war 2 than the speeches of a white
supremacist well can always catch that
on the side
one day Riker came into the holy city
bar and saw a bottle of scotch labeled
black and white the bartender said he
accelerate that label well the bartender
said Riker exploded into a rage and
demanded the bartender turn it around so
no one can see the colors mingling oh my
seriously alcohol and yeah they have a
bar
what sort of tenements they're left I
don't know no drinkin coming out to the
saloon now [ __ ] we got a peepshow
Ryker began to grow paranoid that
unspecified enemy planes are going to
drop bombs on holy city so so we're
finally we've arrived yeah so he had
some disciples build emergency ladders
on the sides of all the buildings yeah
that helps with bombs get closer to the
bomb sorry they're coming hold on photos
they hang on I was kind of listening he
had them paint ladders build your
pitching makes more sense Hey latter's
he's pitching a wily coyote yeah all
right here's what you do draw cliff and
we'll walk over it as long as nobody
looks down and it learns about gravity
we're gonna be fine the disciples were
now also on edge according to a paper
quote fatally bludgeoned with an iron
bar during an argument over how
emergency fire ladders were to be
constructed on holy city buildings was
Joseph's wits ago carpenter he died
shortly after being clubbed by IB
fissure 60 who also seriously injured
Arthur Kastner 62 before running away
into the mountains
what senior warfare 62 hammer murder in
the mountains for what I assume would be
a death that evening oh [ __ ] my meds
well he he ended up turning himself in
to authorities and got five years in San
Quentin you killed a guy so never killed
a guy with a hammer five years but he
gets to San Quentin and he goes well at
least there's no how far women but oh
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] on the other ones he was
warned to never return to holy city
again which he did in 1942
Iker ran again for governor and lost
again by a landslide and he would run
again in 1946 the San Francisco
Chronicle Rikers platform as indicated
by his paid ads stresses racial issues
he wants to protect the white race from
all others you just don't say it out
loud anymore we do now wait till this
year finishes and then says you wait
till this year finishes you [ __ ] wait
till this year Burt hold my mic beat
Dave like I'm 62 and got a date with the
woods in December of 1947 an office
officer niece went to a bar in San Jose
he found a trail of blood leading all
the way to a nearby shanty house that
really happened he knocked on the door
and Williams son Francois entered and so
I had a broken ankle head and chest
wounds bruising all over his body and
cuts on his face Francois said he had
left the Divine way years ago but some
members found him and tried to convince
him to return what applying to so they
brutally beat him boss Betsy's son he's
right he's right
I was listening by the way I'm pretty
drunk right now
[Laughter]
when niece asked him to identify the
assailants Francois declined a quote he
would have killed me if I did he didn't
want the police involved for 60 year old
white guys covered in blood this gang of
60 year olds that's right we got irons
and hammers and wrenches no never told
us golf yeah that's right yeah we'll
meet at dusk I go to sleep it does all
right
we meet a little before dusk for Andy
Andy what time would work way too much
give me the hammer
close your eyes Indy you're gonna make
boom-boom forever now pal you're gonna
love the next phase then brother some
tourists were called that in the early
years of holy city record often tell
visitors and his disciples quote I had a
son but thank God I got rid of him it's
Francois yeah but days after the attack
Francois changed his mind any identified
cult member Jack Coburn s'en who was
charged with assault and jailed and then
Francois disappeared by the late 40s
holy city was barely functioning from
the san franpsycho Chronicle 1948 the
only establishment in town which still
looks purpose prosperous is and was also
a Foster's prosperous and well-kept is
Rikers home which stands on a knoll at
the head of the main and only street
record took care of wrecker a mere
twenty of the original 200 converts
remain in the colony
and most of these totter vacant I'd one
of these Riker found waiting for him
outside his house one morning not so
long ago he was hanging dead from a tree
which stands at his doorway so Marlowe
so 19 are left this is what I think
meaning mine and you know how old white
guys get they go has used to be better
when I was a kid you know that that's
all they did every [ __ ] night sober
is [ __ ] 20 years ago [ __ ] no gas
hard-ons the whole year what you think
ada Schwartz is doing now I mean Freda
Fritos on July 4th 1950 the seal wrecker
had a stroke and fell into a nineteen
coma and died at the age of 76 who did
his first wife [ __ ] she Stiller
well the first one he married after he
came back from Canada so otherwise he is
4 so by the mid 50s with his wife dead
and Hitler dead William had no one to
write to boy you got another wife and
your list of a wife and Hitler's left
you nobody to talk to that's how you
know you're pretty low on friends so we
started sending letters to don't you
ever the next person the next person get
this is not good he's on the rebound
from being a pen pal Oh
writing letters to different US
government officials and to the Kremlin
Jesus specifically to Georgie of melon
coffee
Stalin's successor quote decided to
write you an interest letter he's way
too casual decide you write you and
check this box if you want to write back
besides sending you a couple of copies
of special letters that I wrote and sent
to our president and also copy a letter
sent to the Chief Justice I believe that
you will enjoy reading them here are
letters that other people didn't want to
read that we're to them and about them
maybe you can read them is this a weird
way to start a friendship these same
kind of coffees also have been sent to
many other big officials that sit in the
saddle throughout the world in the
letter Riker wrote about his four steps
to becoming progressive and beautiful in
thought and spirit the first three steps
were vague comments about government
striving to reach perfection but the
fourth is the most detailed quote bring
or to cause all of the different
nationalities of the great genteel white
race of people throughout this world to
be and to come under one all new white
race man beautiful flag that is sure to
cause a 1% honey making situation and
honey me these are his words are your
words
no his words this is a hold on one
second I might have my new favorite
thing to say
who's up for a honey making situation
that is [ __ ] brilliant just when I
think I can't listen to anything this
guy says he says a big golden no I just
feel sorry for your wife she'll be in
the middle of all honey making situation
tonight
honey making situate one [ __ ] a 100%
honey making my god I will be using that
a lot a 100% honey making situation oh
[ __ ] that's a pimp talk right there all
right [ __ ]
who's up for a hundred percent honey
making situation how did the Kremlin not
I bet it was in translation they didn't
get it they're like he wants to buy B's
vice he's saying if I B's to protect
their queen that's probable and Stalin
by the way how do I not do a Russian
accent no don't be so hard on yourself
all right so that is sure to cause a
hundred percent honey making situation
can I can I please right now can I say
this on the podcast I am gonna make
t-shirts to say a hundred percent honey
making situation that's great that is
the a hundred percent
honey making situation a hundred that is
the greatest thing I've ever heard in my
life by the way is that [ __ ] weird
that this lunatic connects with me huh
no checked a couple boxes for your bird
I want to read one of his pamphlets now
[Laughter]
that he sure do cause a hundred percent
honey making situation and condition to
come and be in this entire world that is
also symbolic to a honey making be high
but saw with it's all inspiring and life
gaming queen bee that rules in her honey
making hive he finished respectfully
she's over killed it
yeah respectfully submitted father w/e
Riker he could have made that letter so
much better if he was like yo are you
into a hundred percent honey amazing
situation
hit me up Riker
in 1956 Riker found a new business
partner
Maurice Klein a music director from
Hollywood Riker called Klein the quote
new Jewish Messiah wait what a complex
relationship with the Jews he's had huh
he sold Klein half the ownership of holy
city and wrecker broke his hip in a car
accident while he was healing in a rest
home a fire broke out in Holy City's
largest Hall and burned it to the ground
a lot of Williams writings were lost no
[ __ ] Stalin had them all don't worry
in 1957 a record sold the other half of
holy city decline on the condition that
no one preached within its borders
Recker was worried climb was going to
make his decide take his disciples from
him so he sent six of them to meet Klein
this did not go well membered Winifred
Allington quote after hearing Klein new
owner of holy city outline and express
his hopes for the future mrs. Allington
declared we all are well satisfied with
the charge and feel that at last we are
on the main track we have been on detour
a long enough so they all were like this
guy
way better we'll do it but if we could
climb yeah whatever decline okay the
Jewish Messiah yes the Jewish Messiah
spilling groove mixed that's right 100%
honey making situation but a few months
later Riker regretted selling and went
to the Santa Clara Superior Court to get
his property back the legal fight went
on for two years the state of California
ruled that Maurice Klein was the sole
owner of holy city Klein started tearing
down buildings and remodeling them only
keeping the original restaurant but
nothing was bringing back the tourists
soon the town was unincorporated another
fire broke out of their building was
destroyed San Francisco Chronicle quote
Jim Edmondson who runs the garage at
Holy City reported that he received an
anonymous call Thursday from a caller
who had already caused about
500 damage to the garage in another
building it was the second major fire in
three months Maurice Klein reported that
he received threats by mail and
telephone that the community would be
burned
identify about Cadillacs that he's just
turning the lights off like a mile from
the property in 1966 William Riker was
now in his 90s and confined to a
wheelchair I'm still 90 years old he
only had a few disciples left racists
have the longest lifespan it's crazy
like they always live to their 90 yeah
it just keeps him going 90 yeah yeah he
shines this before blood-pressure
medicine yeah oh yeah yeah he's an
anomaly didn't have Alzheimer's didn't
have cancer didn't [ __ ] 90 maybe what
if he was right guys like you know the
only one who got it who else was crazy
well he's in his 90s not just 90 so he
shocked all his disciples that were left
when he suddenly converted to
Catholicism I'm cat oh now go home no I
was wrong go home
holy [ __ ] the register name of the new
city by the way this story only ends
perfect if he lives to be 100 the
register on July 29 1966 what William
Riker founder of holy city a cultist
retreat off highway 17 south of Los
Gatos
yesterday was conditionally baptized as
a Catholic wrecker was 94 used to call
himself the wisest man on earth and the
leader of the way said it was becoming a
Catholic I was intelligently converted
I've been living a celibate life for 10
years
the weird thing to tell paper yeah
94 big like now I know and what the
auditor you must have dunking a 94 year
old into water you've got to be like we
got to get him up right away
ok 1 2 3 go up right
the two witnesses at his conversion
ceremony were his first two disciples
I'd be Fisher the murderer and Steven
Ronson what you're really hanging in
there
this is 1966 oh [ __ ] Riker made his
final billboard quote [ __ ] everything by
2020 great billboard quote NOAA
announced the flood and the Messiah is
now announcing the plague to sweep the
earth Noah got the animals together in
there prior in their proper place after
the plague so great billboard man I kind
of wish you went back to your old racist
woods I gotta be honest so he's he's so
does someone have to build the human arc
I don't know who nobody knows
everybody's just left with that puzzling
feeling of like what was he saying
speaking of the park see speaking of Arc
when does this story get to Rikers
Island that's absolute like this whole
[ __ ] time I was like how did he start
this island I get it just hold out
[Laughter]
William Riker died from a heart attack
on December 3rd 1969 at 96 years old so
close so close to the [ __ ] perfect
sentence yeah he had been sent to a
state hospital for months prior quote
because of it was his extreme age and
inability to get along with anyone in
private rest homes
[Music]
that tracks he had three disciples left
who were these people now get up go away
leave me alone he has spoken
dick mashed potatoes got too much skin
in him look we must fix his potato dish
he is the chosen one no I'm not a slime
I'm Catholic now Jesus Christ oh we're
all Catholic with you sir rancor we will
follow you anywhere
can't get the [ __ ] away from me aah get
away from him but not too far because
we're still his disciples is the chosen
one we're not gonna be around a guy like
that I bet it feels so good to be a
disciple she's just honey nobody out and
just be like no that's my dude rider
[ __ ] die why will someone start a
cult now I'm in Albert they're out there
don't worry you'll get one yours is
coming hey hit me up and Romeo horse
cocky gmail.com if you've got a Colt and
you need like some press I am [ __ ]
buzz yeah I mean yeah it's like you're
cult you could start your own you don't
need someone to initiate a group you can
stock the confidence you've got to get
my pamphlet all the time you guys showed
up again today I can't believe it look
people are beckoned begging for ging for
it do it this is not most people have to
start from with nothing they started
caught with nothing would I I wouldn't
wanna have sex with other people's wives
I just want to run bits by them
no seriously runs new bits by the week
they'll be like do you just want to [ __ ]
my wife would that be easier
[Laughter]
Francois Francois was not listed in his
in his obituary ownership of holy city
switched hands various times of the
years but no one developed it it became
more and more of a ghost town and as a
2015 only one building remained in holy
city a glass art shop with a sign that
reads holy city art glass holy city
California in 2016
Robert and Patricia Duggan bought the
land for six million dollars half the
asking price
since Patricia Doug is an artist Robert
Duggan is an entrepreneur in surgical
robotics Ethernet innovations and
biotech he recently made three point
five billion after selling an oncology
drug to the pharmaceutical research and
development company AB V as of 2013
after a shocking 20 million donation
Robert Duggan is the largest financial
supporter of the Church of Scientology
David that was the end this is like the
Harry Potter movies where they just
bleed into each other but that was that
was me making situation
[Laughter]
[Applause]
well [ __ ] thank you guys No oh wait
research was by Shirin Assad rapport and
do the wrong sources
Richard Beale highway 17 the road to
Santa Cruz
Leona Claire fuller holy city California
my father's final quest well yeah
Betty Lewis holy city records roadside
attraction in the Santa Cruz Mountains a
nostalgic history and John V young ghost
towns of the Santa Cruz Mountains
yeah about that now
hey big boy on Netflix March 17th birdie
boy world tour give it up for Bert
Kreischer
thank you everybody thank you guys thank
you for having me appreciate it thank
you guys
you